so today I'm here thanks thanks everyone
for coming I really appreciate it and we
appreciate the time to take you guys
take to listen to what we're doing and
today we're going to talk about
infrastructure and specifically what
we've been working on with customers
over the last year and a half within
their infrastructure to do tearing and
tearing you know it's there's a lot of
different names for it there's our kyv
there's heterogeneous storage we're
gonna cover how we've helped the
customer do tearing within their
environment why they're doing tearing
and give you a little details about how
you can successfully tear in your
environment by the way is anybody worked
with the tearing function in Hadoop a
heterogeneous storage or archive or
storage policies or types anybody have
you any of you worked with it it's
fairly new in terms of Hadoop itself but
it's actually been in production since
2.6 about one and a half years two years
or so this capability has been in Hadoop
so storage policies and disk types
really make up what is called tearing or
heterogeneous storage in Hadoop today
those are the two main components of it
the storage policy defines what storage
you're actually moving the data to so
here's all the different ones these are
all built in a dupe you can't change
them this is this is static but they are
very flexible they don't have to be a
specific storage type they're tied to
the law does did this type that you see
here Ram disk SSD those are just
definitions of the storage itself but
you can assign up to any local file
system so you can really you know you
have the flexibility to use these disk
types in whatever kind of storage that
you want or data node that you want and
I'm going to show you an example of that
where archive is just a type of data
node that you've configured a different
SKU in other words
the storage policy is set on the parent
directory and everything underneath it
inherits all directories and files
beneath will inherit that particular
storage policy you can override that by
setting it just on the file itself so
you can you can move all the way to file
granularity they file at a particular
place now one thing I want to mention
here is this that you're not really
moving the data in terms of the file
system this is completely transparent to
the HDFS HDFS sees that file in the same
place it was before but underneath the
covers it'll move to a file system that
has an attribute a tied to that disk
type that you defined in your Hadoop
environment so it's very very
transparent as far as where your data
lives within it within Hadoop ok so the
first question I asked when a customer
said hey we want to archive our data in
Hadoop and we want to tear it the first
question I asked was why isn't it
already commodity storage I mean why
what are you gonna why are you gonna
tear it so it's a question that I had
right off the bat and something I
actually became very passionate about
over the last year in working and
working on this project so it is it
isn't really commodity storage in Hadoop
you know you tie
storage to compute so your jobs don't
suffer and I'll talk about that so it's
it's not really even though the disk
itself is commodity disk the data node
and the data nodes that comprise your
capacity within Hadoop that is actually
fairly expensive when it comes to that
type of storage in today's market and
why is that well you have your disk here
and in a typical deployment you have a
kind of a lower disk capacity per
compute that's kind of a best practice
in to do why because it's very good for
job scalability for job perform
and you get pretty consistent results
because you're not waiting and queuing
up for your jobs when you're doing
billions of transactions to do Frank
guys so that's good the bad news is it's
about five to ten times more expensive
per gigabyte because you have so little
capacity for every compute and data know
that you put into your environment so
this is up this is a fairly you know
once once as I understood this from the
customer it made so much sense to me and
then we started to go along the path of
okay well how do we solve this right we
have those functions that I talked about
already in Hadoop you know they put it
there for a reason so now you know we
can see the reason I can get much lower
storage per gigabyte right if I just
pile a bunch of disks on the compute
node but what do I worry about if I'm a
dupe administrator or a dupe developer
I'm worried that my jobs will be
inconsistent if I start plugging in and
it's completely transparent to HDFS if I
start plugging in all these very dense
nodes in my environment I can get kind
of inconsistent results I can start
seeing performance degradation in my
Hadoop environment and that's something
obviously I don't want to happen right
so therein lies a rub you know I have
this capability but I don't want my jobs
to suffer but I do want to save money on
my overall environment and I want to get
more capacity for my data so I can store
more data that's readily available in
Hadoop for analytics so the ideal is
this and this is my fancy animation I
swear it's long fancy animation I did
but I am kind of a PowerPoint I like
PowerPoint the ideal is this that I move
my hot data to that node where I have
lower capacity and more compute and I
move my cold data to that archive layer
right that's going to give me the best
performance it's actually going to free
resources up here which is going to be
better for
or mints and it's going to get that cold
data over here now the whole cold data
over here can still be processed and
processed at a very fast pace as long as
you're putting data that's very seldomly
access there right you still have
compute resources over there so it
actually would be pretty good as long as
the data is fairly you know not accessed
often so this is the ideal scenario much
less per gig on your overall
infrastructure more resources to process
jobs on that higher compute better class
of dis storage environment that's the
ideal that's what we're shooting for as
I work through with the customer this is
really what we're trying to do so and by
the way we've been working on this
project for about a year and a half so
I'm new I had about twenty minutes I'm
gonna try to really go quickly through
this but I can give you guys any details
that you want is as we're socializing
afterwards so I want to utilize this
archive storage mechanism but I don't
want performance to suffer so what do I
do to make sure that doesn't happen
the answer is intelligent tearing and
that's kind of where I've kind of
invented this pillars of intelligent
data archiving
for Hadoop so really you need all these
things in order to make sure that that
data that you put in archive is going to
be data that is not going to affect the
performance of your environment and give
you the capacity that you want at the
lower price you want if you just did age
for instance that that is easy to that
is very easy to find out in your
environment right I can look at all my
files and I can just say all these files
move to archive I can run a little batch
job to go ahead and do that set the
policy and start the mover to go out and
do it in Hadoop the problem is and I put
a big caution here is that if you're
just using age and that day
still being accessed you can hit
performance problems and you can get
user complaints I'll give you an example
one customer that we have an
installation of our software installed
that we looked at their data it was
about seven petabytes of data logical
petabytes you know there's replicas
obviously about seven petabytes of
logical data over two petabytes was data
that they actually access for more than
90 days so this data should never ever
go into archive this is data that
they're constantly accessing all the
time but when you're talking about
millions of millions of files in Hadoop
and hundreds of millions and even
billions in some case and I did a true
hyper scale environment this is really
hard to find that data right so this is
all the things that you want to see you
want to see heat when's the last time I
access that file how many times have I
accessed that file that is going to be
the most important one and it's it is
there that information is in a dupe it's
just not easy to get it's not that easy
to get but it is in there
we have metadata in Hadoop that we can
extract that gives us that information
and I'll talk about that we want the
size you know the last thing we want to
do is move our zero byte files that are
laying all over our file system to a
different a different place what a waste
right they're already they're already
wasting resources on the name node
there's no reason to send a copy command
for all these zero files by the way
that's something that that is a really
big one you know there's there are
problems to solve there are zero byte
files Lane one customer we went to we
had a hundred and fifty million zero
byte files and they were all just
results files from MapReduce jobs over
the over the years that they've had
their Hadoop cluster running and they
just left them there you know and once
we remove those files the cluster
actually booted up five hours faster
than it did previously to removing those
files so Hugh
huge impact so size is important not
only for that but you know if I want to
get the biggest bang for my buck when
I'm moving data if I know I'm moving big
data for big data files first that
haven't been accessed for a long time
I'm going to get those over to the
archive faster and take advantage of
that storage that I'm buying cheaper in
my archive layer and then the last one I
want to talk about is usage so sometimes
this is referred to as the velocity of
the data right
once I ingest the files how long am I
using that data how long is it one day
well you'd be surprised how much data is
just used for a day and then never
touched again there's quite a bit from
from what we've seen so far but I'll be
obviously there's other cases where
there's data access from long periods of
times months years so understanding that
is also important in in planning for how
much archive you want how much of this
archive do I really want to implement
into my environment knowing how that how
the usage patterns of your data your
data velocity goes that is going to be a
very important metric so really all
these together give you kind of the
complete picture of utilizing this
tiering function that was in a dupa dupa
was great to put this in there they were
really great to put this feature in
there it really helps you you know
optimize infrastructure and save money
but you really need the data and the
metrics to make it effective and that's
really what we've been working on that's
what we've been passionate about so as
we've gone through these exercises with
customers we've actually built a product
a software product that will actually do
this and our approach is this we only
want to work with HDFS we don't want to
install any software on the cluster and
we don't want to require any changes to
the cluster no configuration changes
whatsoever so we just want to extract
that metadata information give you a
visualization on how your data is being
used in
heat reports and user reports what users
are are creating all these small files
you know what what application or user
is doing that so we give you a
visualization and it's kind of funny one
customer refers to this as analytics on
the analytics data right that's that's
really what we're doing we're giving you
information on how your data is used in
the environment and we're doing that
through extracting that that metadata
information now we do that through the
existing API is just like name notes
transfer the metadata across name nodes
we can go ahead and copy those files as
well through the same mechanisms and
same api's so nothing for you to do but
give us a server to run the software on
and then once you see these reports and
you run your custom query say oh I want
to see all the data that hasn't been
touched for 120 days and I want to move
that to archive if you want to run a
report that implements that type of rule
we can go ahead and give you a
optimization engine that'll go ahead and
break that into you know this could the
first time we ran this at the last
customer I installed that it was 86
million files that were eligible to go
to archive ok you don't want to send a
job with 86 million files right you want
to filter by size application you want
to make sure and ensure that they're in
smaller useable batches and keep track
of what is moved and what hasn't right
all that stuff you want to do and we've
built an engine to do that as well
because because you really need to do it
you really need to automate this at
scale you can't do it manually but we'll
show you the data first ahead of time
again the software looks like this we
just communicate with the with the name
nodes it sits on a virtual machine you
know we need a if you're hyper scale
we'll need a little bit more than 32
gigs of ram but you know in general 32
gigs of ram as a rule of thumb gets us
all the data and and and does a
processing fast enough on most to dupe
clusters that we've seen out there we do
all the
seen there on that virtual machine again
no software your your cluster is
pristine we've been installed in the
middle of Christmas in environments
because all we're doing is really
copying a few metadata files every
couple hours and then we're crunching
them and giving you the results so my
last slide in general this is this is
what we're trying to do we're trying to
give you the ability to to understand
what data should move to archive help
you move it to archive so you can lower
the the hardware costs and software
costs and get the better performance and
free of the resources that you need to
process the data that you now care about
the process the data that you're you're
actively doing analytics on you know
that that is what we're really trying to
do and there's other things you can get
from these deep storage insights with in
Hadoop you can understand like I said
earlier with user reports and directory
of course I can understand who's
creating all these small files in my
environment what what is doing what
application is doing that what user ID
when you plan for expansion and growth
you'll know you know how much of my data
am I actually processing so that data
needs to stay on a certain type of data
node and then the data that I'm not
using but but want there and I want it
available because I might have to come
back to it at some point and I want it
still in Hadoop moving that data to an
archive layer so you'll be able to do
all these things with our software we
you know our software has evolved now to
the point where it's about a 15 minute
install it takes us a couple hours for
initial baseline to give you this
information we can go back in time I was
mentioning to the Intel team here the
first the first time we built the
software to do this it was on a billion
transaction Hadoop cluster
and it took us a debt you know to
process the day's information it took us
a day right to go through all those
transactions and rebuild this this
shadow of the file system in our
environment that we can query and now
we're we're down to about you know we
can do about ten days on that type of
environment in one day so we've really
refined the process we we got the
metrics so if anybody's interested in
you know getting a snapshot of their
environment and seeing this type of
information and storage insights out of
it we'd be happy to to stop by and just
install the software and let you guys
take a look and at what your environment
looks like today we'd be happy to do
that
so with that I'll open it up to any
questions yes yes so the question is are
we moving the files on the back end when
we want to move it to archive say and
the answer is no and yes
so Hadoop has the mechanisms built into
it to do that so just like balancer if
you assign a policy of four copies of
the data and you only had three before
what does balancer do balancer goes
ahead and the name note says know I'm
supposed to have four copies of that
file go ahead and do that that's what
that's what balancers job is right mover
is exactly the same for storage policy
so if I say this storage policy now has
archive the next time mover is executed
it will go ahead and read that policy
and move it so what are when we say we
will help you automatically optimize
what we do is we actually will change
the storage policy on the files that you
want to change the storage policy for
and we'll do that in batches we won't do
it all at once
we won't changes all 86 million files
and change the storage policy that would
be bad because when Mover runs it's
gonna try to do everything just like
balancer would
right so we try to make it in useable
batches and you define the criteria
really you tell us how much per day or
how much per hour or what size files you
want to move or you know any any of that
information answer your question great
and again I'm sorry one other data point
there just just emphasize in a dupe
itself it doesn't move right the
filesystem sees the file exactly in the
same place even though it's moved to a
different storage type it's exactly in
the same place so it's not like a backup
or archive folder and I do yeah policies
are applied to either directories and
then everything at that directory all
sub directories and files inherit that
policy automatically so when we when we
are looking at what policies you have in
place for your data we actually have to
do that this is why it takes us a little
bit of time to do the analytics on the
data is we have to recursively go
through and apply the policy to all
those files from that parent right so
you can do that or you can override it
even to the file level I can apply a
policy a storage type I mean I'm sorry a
storage policy to a file storage policy
in Hadoop is tied to a storage type you
can see here now that we've kind of you
know defined what storage policies are
right you can see here that if I'm doing
the S it let's say I'm doing one SSD I
want one copy on SSD it's gonna be one
copy of the data file on SSD one copy I
mean sorry two copies on disk if I'm
doing three if I have four replicas it's
gonna be one and three right so this is
how it works these are how these work
together archive which is I think this
is kind of the use case that's the best
right now for archive cold is the policy
name
so everything is going to go to the
archive layer all copies that you've
defined for that file are gonna go to
archive does that make sense
actually no we don't need any hints or
keys
we actually recreate the file system in
all transactions that happen on the file
system on our analytics engine so we're
actually doing the analytics already so
we're seeing that that file hasn't been
touched for 90 days we know it because
we're reading the filesystem metadata
and all the audit logs and the edits yes
there is there are there is definitely
but the the that information again is in
our analytics reports that's one of the
analytics reports we do so we give you a
usage report once we do analytics we
give you base reports we give you heat
reports we give you usage reports we
give you replica reports so how many
replicas of data do I have surprising
least you know when people run out of
space sometimes they'll just move
everything to two copies just to make
space and then they forget about it and
pretty soon you have a petabyte of data
that's it on two copies you know so we
give you that all basically all kinds of
insights users how users are using the
data what kind of data that they're
they're introducing into Hadoop or
copying in I mean I'm sorry ingesting
into Hadoop is the proper term all this
information is there as we do our
analytics and we're getting it all from
the metadata we're not we're not going
to the file system and walking through
the file system we're not doing any of
that we're getting the FS image file the
audits files the edits files and then
we're taking those in and we're doing
analytics on that
we get it from the metadata so let me
give you an example of multiple servers
in action here right let's say we have
an H a configuration I have my two name
notes and I have my journal notes so our
software automatically will say ok this
is an H a configuration please tell me
the primary name node and the secondary
name node and then from that information
we can get everything we need to know
about the cluster where all the metadata
lives where all the journal nodes are
and we can go ahead and extract that
data from there so if you have the FS
image file you have the edits files and
you have the audits files you have all
the information I talked about here in
the pillars it's just hard very very
hard to extract it took us a year and a
half to build something that would do it
effectively and efficiently and we have
it down to a to such a level now that we
can really if you just want if you say
hey Pete I just want to see you know we
want to see if this is going to be
useful for us if you if you you know can
you come in and just install it and we
can just take a snapshot look at our
environment we can do that in about you
know 15 minutes to half an hour you have
the software running and then it takes
us about six hours to do an initial
baseline because them again we have to
we have to basically recreate the file
system from a metadata perspective on
our on our system that you're giving us
makes sense
any other questions thanks a lot for
your time guys I really appreciate it
thank you